he pushes his pawn that is not the kind  of move he wants to play black's knight  now will act as a defender but dude  wanted to go on the attack  and now liam whoa nice move attacking  the black queen and where is she going  she has to retreat  feels like it's so close to winning now  for liam if he can break through and  attack that black king how does he do it  okay but he's played it to the night now  comes he said black is now trying to  attack as well that night threatening to  jump in he could still go either  weightless yeah i'm so brave ignoring  the white king and the threats to it  going for the black queen now  centralizing  there's a big check on the board that's  a massive check and uh oh he's got the  queen he has pinned the queen to the  king that is the end oh that is the end  so a win for liam ledan and the first  blitz game with the white pieces they  now have five minutes to prepare